en réalité quand on appelle la campagne
93 ont nettement deux blocs mais le bloc
je le tenais blesse lui surtout due à
cette élection là est un des thèmes de
campagne
je t'ai que c'était la première et la
dernière qu'en fait encore ce matin il
est éligible pour contempler la nouvelle
mine à lewarde j'abuse parfois bien sûr
où là où des cadres des tee-shirts
oui je l'aï vu que c'était j'ai conservé
weill est certain que j'arrête d'être
porté à lui faire face à la russe après
c'est facile et nous fuit la réalité et
j'étais cuit là dessus sachez du
matériel de campagne distribué choc de
beauté légende j'étais cuit reçu je vais
travailler à la première et dernière
campagne du bloc québécois avec le chef
du bloc les bacs aujourd'hui quand vous
dis cela pour moi c'est renvoyé
moonwatch est sans contexte super jo ou
rappelés par lesdits trois périodes ses
pions successives
montez la souveraineté avec l'élection
du pq à 94,12 frais chié dans 93 pour la
période bien la position officielle aps
la troisième affaire c'était d'arrêter
madame où on occupe un terrain du québec
avec 54 députés fédéraux j'avais des
budgets des du personnel des cabinets
dans toutes les régions du québec qui
prenait bien d autres pourquoi qui
luttait contre madame donc c'était prévu
tout ça était avancé c'est vrai qu'on en
voyait chacune minerais rares était rien
dans le but gagnant en ayant créé toutes
les conditions pour y arriver
donc le bloc n'était pas prévu c'est
tellement vrai que le soir du référendum
quand on rentre à la maison après la
défaite de 95,1 me souviens grâce
évidemment
avait conduit le texte interne ait rendu
à la maison là c'est clair on apprit
l'addition tous les deux mois de repos
libres de nous convaincre je finissais
la cession à ottawa on était en avant
des champions puis ça finit toujours
entrer à montréal et que je dois tourner
la pratique du droit c'était vraiment un
soin qu'on avait décidé qu'en
championnat travail lent mais moi je
savais que la dernière fois que viale
est d'autant plus la journée témoigne
surtout d'un livre on arrêtait déjà
restaurant mon temps on s'est
littéralement fait assaillir par 10 500
points il était invité sur la veille
votre voix alors ouais donc des raisons
d'être resté non non pas de phrase je
dis pas qu'elle m'a échappé mais j'ai
quand même une phrase que son sens pour
moi
dans les faits vous visiez que certains
jeux gare sinon à tous les égards
la portière du doigt car ottawa cela dit
vu nos invités le pouvoir politique du
québec à l'intérieur de la fédération
parce que c'est quand vous envoyez de
voir comment ils faisaient autre voie
une députation où différents sur sertic
un hippie dans le cas des vidéos
il ya des fortes chances que vous avez
des poids lourds du cabinet puis l'avait
quant au tour de table où le vent
glacial essentielle qui vous êtes là qui
vous avait du poids si vous avez des
convictions
vous allez en avait fait le produit
québec d'aller voir la police et qui
sort alors on y va pour naviguer vous
comme c'est facile même avec bonne foi
de nous ignorer laquelle 6 surtout
qu'avec bloc et je suis complètement
soit lui permet de juin dit si drôle
mais je parle qu'on peut pas échapper à
cette réflexion alors quand on pense
quand on passe au dessus